you dare enter this house
it's Monday [__] smooth
[__] it's Monday it's a
beautiful day to be alive
November 13th I want to see nothing but
[__] and [__] hell balls
you follow me New York City thank you
very much for the great weekend that
Gotham sold out there was a fight chairs
were [__] flying but that's what the
church is all about every once in a
while you gotta throw a chair up and
[__] air and let people know what
time it is
besides that it's Monday it's your main
[__] date today's your main day well
you gotta come out the box like a
[__] savage if you hurt somebody's
feelings [__] that's what feelings
are for remember Monday in the party
until somebody takes that dick up so
[__] it you follow me let's get this
party started today and let's go on the
right directions
I did my 22 [__] push-ups I took my
daughter to school and I wrote my goals
and now I'm ready for the week of my
[__] life you understand me tomorrow
night tonight we got the podcast eight
o'clock the Church of what's happened
now so never fear uncle Joey's here
Tuesday I got the showcase down for
Netflix and [__] The Comedy Store
belly room I want nothing but murderers
wrote down there I want real get read it
was down there then they're gonna yell
scream we're gonna [__] blow [__] up
Wednesday I got some Disney [__]
thing I gotta go see Coco with my
daughter and then Wednesday morning let
another podcast for you [__]
it's that type but we put them never
mind me it's all about you today they
could all suck your dick you follow me
you're coming out of that [__] hole
like a savage you don't give a [__]
there's gonna be buys on a Puerto Rico
when you get through with these
[__] telling bodies everywhere
because that's mindset you gotta have
that's the [__] attitude you gotta
have on a Monday
there's no giggling I'm Monday I got
some tremendous weed here today too I
got some chocolate chunk I got the
devil's advocate and I got the devil get
Habakkuk cuz we're gonna throw a go
through all three of them cuz you know
what we don't [__] around we don't leave
the house unless were prepared beside
that I want to congratulate Tiffany
Haddish she's one of us she's one of the
ones that worked really hard for years
and nobody [__] talked and then at
the end she [__] just let him know
who the [__] she was in the cast of wall
stars you follow him Santi when you see
people like that you gotta go you know
what that chicks been fighting from day
one and nobody gave her dick thank God
she got to where she got so again my
[__] heart goes out to Tiffany's for
being a [__] savage you follow me
let's do another bomb what the [__] who
gives a [__] it's Monday I don't want
you to leave the house and somebody pull
the wool over your eyes won't let nobody
pull the wool over your eyes today I fit
this society does a bunch of [__]
pullovers but you don't give a [__]
you're blocking [__] don't even think
you're gonna get me with that one
[__] wait the guy just fell off
the [__] boat get your [__] together
[__]
ah feels good to be a [__] gangster I
want to get my main man Renee and cause
stealing a shout-out over there
came to the show Saturday night from
Puerto Ricans he's over there doing
everything he can for the Puerto Ricans
I want to give a shout out to my man
when that's the two brothers their
great-great great-grandfather signed the
Declaration of Independence they were
there my man
TJ [__] English the author of a Vanna
Nocturne and the Westies and the Future
author of [__] the corporation
he was there I mean we had a great
[__] show so I'm happy that your
[__] came out it was great to
go home and see my friends you know just
to sit there with my friends eating that
I did something to me it reminded me I
love you I was where I was and where I
am now you know people change people
[__] change behavior look at your
wife ten years they're gonna look at
what you're doing now
you got small enough people [__]
change so before you crucify people give
people a chance
they're majestic too right the mistake
sir hey 15 years ago I was a [__]
mess and here we are today
am I still a mess yes but I'm in the
control and I got you guys watching my
back which means I can't [__] fail
because that's what we do we watch each
other's back what a church family if
you're lacking wheat with them you
follow me
your sisters got cancer will [__]
they're not that whatever be a
helicopter what a screw social media
letting you know to hang in there you
follow me
after the church is about man so before
I go crucifying [__] people you know
I've been there I've been on the other
hand in fact that went home this week
and somebody told me that one of the
houses I got accused of robbing as a kid
the one that hurt me the most it was a
false accusation I mean don't get me
wrong they had every [__] right to
point their finger at me cuz I'm a piece
of [__] thief I knew that going in but I
knew I hadn't robbed the house on the 30
years later somebody came clean that
they had robbed the house do I call the
people at marathon they go [__]
themselves no I got stronger from that
you follow me so hey every date is a
[__] learning adventure get to church
and I'll let you guys know cuz I know
you guys gotta go out there and impose
your will on these [__] [__]
nothing happens in the fall sitting on
the couch like an [__] dreaming
dreams are good until extent complete
you got a [__] execute you follow me
dreams is great right in your dreams
down and let people know what you want
to do but dreams don't get [__]
fulfilled on the couch [__] so get
up get out there get the [__] knife I
don't give a [__] back back a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich or you ain't
coming home unless you got a half a yard
with 200 in your pocket whatever [__]
is your goal for the deck
I'm installing this morning I have
[__] of meeting this afternoon I have
some riding this morning I got you to it
12 of my buddy what else I got today
I got an audition and then we got a
podcast at 8 now to pick my daughter up
in school you know how we do it it
doesn't [__] stop it doesn't [__]
stop I'm working harder now than when I
was a [__] burglar you follow me when
I was at birth what life was great
all I did was crawl through [__]
windows but obviously now grew that
[__] position and now I'm cracking
jokes with you [__] but it's
not jokes it's my heart that's why
nobody could say [__] to Maxie years ago
I decided before anybody attacks me with
that [__] I'm gonna put it all out
there the [__] podcast whether it's
right or wrong
I don't we have a [__] from the time I
stole the change on the car that one for
Lee that kidnapping too whatever the
[__] because he got nowhere to go
that's the secret right there I got no
skeletons in my closet except maybe
wanted to I don't really give a [__]
about them either
because at the end of the day we did it
we got the end I made it to 15 and
that's all that gives a [__] I am rich I
don't have a helicopter
I don't have [__] celebrity friends
and I don't want none of that [__] I
just wanna be me and had the [__]
Church family I got you you got me and
they want to be with us
that's what mondays are about five six
of my [__] family friends and that
was it I'm good for the [__] year
seeing your friends is good for the
[__] soul we'd have to smoke weed we
could none we sat down we broke a little
bread 20 30 minutes and that's it there
was no fake hugs
there was no [__] picture she's not
to know that [__] that's it that's my
[__] thing beside that I had no
thought dates everything sold that the
night before Thanksgiving so down Irvine
and I got Sacramento in December that's
it and that's that I'll see you all the
[__] tonight in the Church of what's
happened now as far as you're concerned
you've got a mission for the day to be
the best you can be
you don't need to come home with a
million dollars that that's all [__]
as long as you feel good about your
[__] day you did it [__] and
everybody else gets up your dick so or
you didn't get mom might della Vigna oh
I forgot these secrets are from
California sorry
uncle Joey here telling you at all about
you today it's Monday November whatever
the [__] it is it don't matter it's just
another day and you got to do the same
thing you did yesterday
it's be a [__] Savage you understand
me I'll see you tonight
eight o'clock be there or be square
[__] oh yeah